monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
madame la ministre vous avez dans vos
propos
introductifs fait état qui fallait pas
constamment se référer au passé sur les
grenades les salaires revenir aux années
68 aux années 68 si vous me le permettez
moi je vais revenir au 18e siècle et
notamment aussitôt citant un exemple
repris par Marx dans le capital et il
disait à la fin du XVIIIe siècle et
pendant les 20 premières années du 19e
les fermiers et les landeslords Anglais
rivalisèrent d'efforts pour faire
descendre le salaire à son minimum
absolu
à cet effet on payait moins que le
minimum sous forme de salaire et on
compensé le déficit par l'assistance
paroissiale
madame la ministre nous vivons de nos
jours une situation analogue
votre gouvernement imagine régulièrement
de nouveaux dispositifs pour compenser
les salaires trop bas elles ont été
citées mais la prime d'activité la prime
exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat et
dernièrement l'indemnité inflation font
partie intégrante de cette Arsenal
par la prééminence de ces dispositifs
aux entretenez une situation dans
laquelle les montants les salaires sont
insuffisants pour vivre et les
travailleurs sont plus en plus soumis à
la contingence de ces aides
force et de constatée que nous parlons
pas du même dialogue social
nous vous parlons salaire vous nous
parlez de prime
pour mémoire je rappelle que la
rémunération annuelle nette d'un salarié
payé au niveau du SMIC se répartit
désormais en 84% de salaire et 16% de
primes de pouvoir d'achat versé par
l'État ces primes représentent
l'équivalent d'un 13e mois de salaire
d'un 14e et même un peu plus autant de
rémunération qui devraient être du
salaire par ces dispositifs l'argent
public vient substituer des revenus à
des salaires en ce sens cette stratégie
est une aubaine pour les entreprises à
court terme leur salarié touche plus
pour un coût maîtrisé et à long terme
les salaires restent bas mais il y a des
perdants ce sont les travailleurs qui
eux perdent le sur presque tous les
plans car leur revenu devenu
imprévisible
car je rappelle qu'une distribué par
l'État peut s'arrêter à tout moment
alors qu'un salaire ne peut être baissé
de façon unilatérale par l'employeur par
ailleurs leur progression salariale de
carrière est ralentie enfin pour la
double peine il cotise moins pour leur
retraite car ses revenus ne sont pas
soumis à cotisations sociales ce constat
est sans appel et ne se limite pas au
secteur privé loin s'en fout désormais
du côté du salaire diverses primes et
indemnités plus ou moins individualisées
occupent désormais une place importante
dans la rémunération des fonctionnaires
elle représente un quart leur
rémunération elles permettent à l'état
de compléter un salaire qui n'augmente
plus ces tensions salariales nous amener
à une approche qui n'est pas uniquement
comptable car à bien y regarder contre
le salaire les dispositifs imaginés
depuis 20 ans en faveur du pouvoir
d'achat sont traversés par un important
sous-entendu
qu'il s'agisse de la prime d'activité la
prime exceptionnelle du pouvoir d'achat
ou de l'indemnité inflation les primes
de pouvoir d'achat ont en commun de
poser les travailleurs comme des êtres
des besoins et de les réduire à cette
condition la question de la satisfaction
de nos besoins notamment matériel est
important et même un contournable mais
sommes-nous seulement des êtres voués à
dépenser ce qui nous est accordé de
façon contingente sur un marché de biens
et services dans la maîtrise nos échappe
totalement le salaire ne se limite pas à
cette condition
telle qui s'est construit au cours du
XXème siècle le salaire permet de
reconnaître le travailleur qu'il soit en
emploi ou hors emploi comme un
producteur de valeur économique
il n'est pas en ce sens étranger que les
revendications salariales se mêlent
souvent revendications entourant les
conditions de travail notre pays n'y
coupent pas et plusieurs mouvements de
grève revendiquant une augmentation des
salaires se sont enclenchés à l'automne
et l'hiver 2021 y compris dans des
secteurs peu enclins ou grève nous avons
pu constater de fortes mobilisations
dans plusieurs enseignes de la grande
distribution
revendications d'augmentation générale
des salaires de l'ordre de 5% les
employeurs ont répondu par des
propositions d'augmentation de 1 ou 2%
et par des mesures contournant le
salaire avec le doublement de
l'indemnité inflation versement de
primes ou encore l'augmentation des
remises en magasin c'est factuels les
primes sont devenues des éléments
importants de rémunération pour les
titulaires de base salaire et finalement
et travailleurs qui mettent en valeur un
capital dans le secteur privé ce pays de
plus en plus eux-mêmes en tant que
contribuable cela n'est pas admissible
dans ce conseil dans ce contexte et
alors que la période de négociation
annuelle obligatoire comment ce mois
à ce que nous conjotions à Grenelle des
salaires avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales afin qu'il
réponde systémique et collégiale soit
apportée aux travailleurs de notre pays
nous sommes aujourd'hui réunis à
l'initiative du groupe socialiste pour
débattre du partage de la richesse créée
dans notre pays
nous pensons que ce partage équitable
doit pouvoir être discuté dans le cadre
d'un Grenelle des salaires
c'est un fait la France manque de bras
dans nombre de secteurs les offres
d'emploi restent sans réponse et les
employeurs s'arrachent les cheveux dans
cette conjoncture le pouvoir politique
tient une responsabilité toute
particulière comme le disait Camus mal
nommé les choses c'est rajouter du
malheur au monde
la première des responsabilités c'est
donc de nommer correctement les mots qui
traversent le monde du travail
contemporain ce n'est qu'une fois
rigoureusement
identifié qu'ils éclairent la
conjoncture actuelle
on peut communément définir la fonction
première du travail comme une manière de
gagner sa vie tout en contribuant à lui
donner du sens à l'inverse quand il ne
permet pas de vivre dignement ou qu'il
se résume à des tâches dont on ne voit
pas la finalité le corps social craque
avec une génération de plus en plus
diplômée et conscientisée bien plus
qu'avant remonte les aspirations des
salariés à des salaires décents ainsi
qu'à une meilleure redistribution et des
conditions de travail plus fidèles à ce
qu'une société moderne se doit d'offrir
la plupart des candidats à l'emploi sont
évidemment attachés au salaire mais dans
le même temps ils attendent de
l'entreprise qu'elles soient sensibles
aux valeurs environnementales le
dialogue social et au respect de la vie
familiale
camp de surcroît la vie familiale et
déstabilisée par des emplois du temps
découpé des temps de transport à allonge
et des logements à prix prohibitifs le
travail devient l'objet d'une longue
plainte journalière et seule sa
rémunération permet de le rendre
acceptable
ne nous guiderons pas la valeur travail
ni droite ni de gauche elle est
universelle en ce sens qu'elle permet
d'émanciper et définir les individus
dans nos sociétés modernes
s'intéresser au salaire c'est
s'intéresser aux fruits du labeur en ce
sens le salaire est évidemment politique
aujourd'hui de quoi dépend le salaire
d'une façon simpliste je serai tenté de
dire que le niveau des salaires peut
être relié à la redistribution du
chiffre d'affaires des entreprises au
sein de deux pôles principaux le salaire
à savoir la rémunération des
travailleurs pour leur travail et les
profits à savoir la rémunération du
capital
en effet en accordant une plus grande
part aux profits on favorise les
détenteurs de capitaux et nos sociétés
postes industrielles tendent à exacerber
cette tendance
à cela s'ajoute de nouveaux modes de vie
moderne qui sont de nature à créer une
nouvelle économie basée sur
l'intelligence artificielle les
impressions 3D les nanotechnologies les
biotechnologies
pouvons-nous penser que cela participe
positivement sur la rémunération des
salariés j'ai du mal à le croire pour
bon nombre d'économistes la robotisation
de l'économie n'aurait pas
nécessairement défait sur l'emploi et la
répartition du revenu
mais en dépit de tous ces
bouleversements macroéconomiques il n'en
reste pas moins que la cause principale
des pénuries soudaines
j'y reviendrai plus tard mais l'exemple
de la restauration est le plus criant
à ce titre il est révélateur que
l'exécutif chante les lois de la loi de
l'offre et de la demande pour toute
décision d'inspiration libérale comme la
dérégulation des salaires des grands
patrons mais trouve révoltant qu'elle
profite pour une fois aux salariés les
moins fortunés
j'entends déjà certains pourendeurs de
l'assistanat présumé nous dire que notre
modèle social n'encourage pas le retour
à l'emploi
je rappelle à toute phase utile que la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre explose même
dans les pays sont droits sociaux comme
les États-Unis ou le Big tweet a
entraîné la démission de près de 5
millions de travailleurs en trois mois
il vous faut donc quitter les postures
faussement moralisatrices sur les gens
qui déconnent dixit le président de la
République et s'attaquer au nœud du
problème
le nœud du problème c'est manifestement
les salaires et nous devons aborder ce
sujet avec honnêteté et ne pas travestir
la réalité car voilà bientôt un an
maintenant qu'une sorte de fable s'est
installée dans le débat public
en croire ceux qui la propagent les
salaires dans le secteur de l'hôtellerie
restauration qui est confronté de longue
date à des tensions de recrutement ont
augmenté tenez-vous bien de 16% cette
année la réalité est tout autre car dans
les faits l'augmentation réelle n'a été
que de 4%
les principaux véhicules de cette
légende sont le patronat et la majorité
gouvernementale qui l'invoque à tout
bout de champ pour contrer les critiques
sur la stagnation des salaires face au
contexte inflationniste mais cela ne
peut pas durer indéfiniment
la question que pose l'augmentation des
salaires c'est surtout la juste
répartition de la richesse entre le
travail et le capital et donc incidament
l'augmentation des plus bas d'entre eux
le cas de l'entreprise totale était
différent
alors que le pétrolier ben un nouveau
record en dégageant un bénéfice de 17
milliards de dollars dans le même temps
les raffineries sont bloquées par des
salariés grévistes demandant une
revalorisation salariale avec un refus
complet de la part de la direction
pourtant dans le même temps le conseil
d'administration du groupe avait annoncé
mi-septembre vouloir je cite partager
avec ses actionnaires les forts
résultats de la compagnie par un acompte
sur dividende exceptionnel soit 2,6
milliards d'euros de plus reversés à ses
actionnaires
le plus inacceptable dans ce conflit
réside indéniablement dans le fait que
le montant que représentait la
revalorisation des salaires demandés par
les salariés représentés seulement 150
millions d'euros supplémentaires chaque
année
2,6 milliards accordés en faveur du
capital contre 150 millions refusés en
défaveur du travail
cet exemple illustre madame la ministre
à lui seul le propos que je tiens et il
est aussi symptomatique des concessions
qui sont communément admises pour le
capital et que l'on refuse
systématiquement pour les revenus du
travail
osons le dire la juste valorisation
salariale du travail est un principe
cardinal en ce sens qu'elle représente
le principal point de friction dans nos
sociétés bien plus qu'un principe
d'égalité c'est aussi le ciment de la
cohésion sociale il est révélateur de
voir que les inégalités de revenus sont
selon une étude du ministère de la Santé
de 2018 parmi les moins acceptés et les
plus ajustements vécus c'est injustice
est d'autant plus mal vécue que les
travailleurs français qu'ils soient
salariés ou indépendants font partie des
plus productifs d'Europe avec près de 15
points au dessus de la moyenne
européenne
justice salariale et rééquilibrage du
revenu du capital sur celui du capital
du revenu du travail sur celui du
capital quel est le prisme mes chers
collègues par lequel doivent être
abordés de débats aujourd'hui sans
dogmatisme ni tabou ne devront pouvoir
collectivement dégager les contours la
Grenelle des salaires que j'appelle de
mes vœux
afin que nos concitoyens puissent
percevoir la transcription tangible de
nos débats et que nous ne nous
contenions pas à des postures partisanes
nos compatriotes nous pressent urgents
soyons à la hauteur collectivement
je vous remercie